i'm delighted to introduce
one of the people who have been with us
and uh for the whole time for these two
months
which you see which we'll be talking
about mean field theory of two-layer
neural networks dimension pre-bounds and
examples
uh thank you
for the introduction is it not too loud
okay it's kind of echoing okay great
thank you katie and simone for inviting
me
and for organizing this
workshop
so i'll talk about min field theory of
two layers neural networks so dimension
free bands and examples
so this is a work we did some time ago
with
song mei and andrea montanari
and also in this talk i'll present some
results from
an earlier work by song andrea and uh
fan min
okay let's
start so
for this talk i decided to spend more
time than usual
on motivating and illustrating the mean
field framework
so i try to
design
this talk keeping the audience of this
workshop in mind so i expect
most of you to be very
familiar with pdas
but a little bit less with the theory of
neural networks
so i started by reviewing some results
on approximation theory for two layers
neural networks
i then described the
mean field description of sgd on players
no nets
i then illustrate this framework
by working out one specific example
which is classifying centered
anisotropic gaussians
i then give some dimension free bounce
between the sgd dynamics and the min
field plea
and i if i have time i'll outline the
proof of this
dimension free bounce
let me start with the setting for this
talk
which is just simply the classical
supervised learning problem
we are given id samples x y y i
so where the x i's are
vector of covariance of d dimension y i
is a scalar
response variable
and so we assume that this y i x i our
id
from a like this command probability
distribution that i denoted p
so the goal is to learn a model f hat
so that given a new data point x new
predicts
uh the response one new via
effect applied to xu
and we measure uh the quality of this
prediction we are the tester with square
loss
so i'll also call it the population risk
throughout the talk
usually we take f hat belonging to a
parametric
function class
meaning that f hat is parameterized by a
vector of parameters theta
and so the goal is to find theta hat
so that the
population risk is
small
and this is
done for example by
minimizing the empirical risk
scientist okay we'll forget about the
empirical risk and only talk about
the population risk
okay so as i said we need a
okay first to choose a family of
functions so it is family needs to be
rich enough
to be able to feed complex data
and so in t-stock we consider the two
layers no networks which is just this
function
so one over n sum of sigma star x theta
i
so and
so we have a big n the number of hidden
units on neurons
sigma star is
the nonlinear activation function
and uh it's parameterized by a parameter
theta i
uh that will call the node collectively
collectively theta
like equal theta 1 to theta
and so h theta i is of dimension big d
and so we have in total n times d
parameters
uh so i just comment about the jargon so
two layers no networks so here
we have one hidden layer
composed of n neurons
followed by one output layer which is
just this averaging of the hidden layer
and so one standard choice is to take
theta i equal to a i b i w i where a i b
i are scalars w i is a vector of
dimension same dimension as a covariate
and so sigma star x theta i is just a i
times sigma
inner product w i x plus the offset
b i
and so we take sigma to be
for example value or sigmoid
so is this uh function class uh rich
enough
uh the response is yes
so this is uh like for example a result
by sebenko in 1989 that proved the
following uh universal approximation
theorem
uh so given
a sigmoid function sigma
meaning that sigma tends to like goes to
one at plus infinity and 2 0 at minus
infinity
then
what you proved or like this is a
slightly stronger modified version
so if f is squared integrable
then for any
epsilon you can find a neural network
that is large enough and that
has
test error on a population risk smaller
than epsilon
so there exists a sequence of neural
networks that
approximate the function arbitrarily
well
okay so
obviously this result is not enough to
say that the two layers neural network
function class is uh interesting so the
most important question is
uh how big should n
be for reasonable functions
um and here is the
celebrated balance theorem
so approved by baron in 1993
so it's famous because it gives
a separation between
neural network and
fixed
basis methods
so in
separation in terms of approximation
power
so basically you take
x the distribute like distributed
with a probability that is supported on
a ball of radius small r
so you assume that the function f
has fourier transform big f
and then d is like uh approximation
error so the population race is bounded
by delta f squared over big n so delta f
is equal to 2 times r
integral of this
weighted
fourier transform
so we see in this case that
the number of neurons required to uh
feature function f of i mean to
approximate your function f
is bounded by this delta f squared over
epsilon
um
so for a
basis
methods
you would need an exponential in the
dimension
number of neurons
so here the point is that delta f can
depend on the dimension
it can be exponential in the dimension
but for
vast
interesting function classes like reach
function this delta f will be
independent of the dimension
and so you'll need only a
constant number of neurons to
approximate them
okay so from this approximation theory
we get some insights on the
properties of neural networks
so first
the proof of the result from the last
slides suggests that it's more
insightful
to
think about neural networks in terms of
a distribution over
the parameters theta
so we write f at x rho
the expectation
over theta of sigma star x theta with
distribution
in the case of um
finite with
neural network we just take a sum of the
rx on the titles
okay so
one uh consequence of
this
representation is that small population
risk is achieved by many neural networks
so what matters is rho
not titan1 to titan
and
the
like
in particular
the
behavior is insensitive to the number of
neurons n
as long as it's large enough for raw hat
n to approximate true
another thing is that
because of baron's theorem we see that
the minimum number of neurons to achieve
certain accuracy depends on the
intrinsic regularity of f and not on the
dimension d
so of course
all these insights
concern ideal representations
and so that doesn't mean that we can
reach them in practice we can't
construct them in practice
so in practice what we do is that we
train
the parameters of the neural networks
using
stochastic gradient descent or its
variance
scientists talk i'll talk about sgd
so we initialize the weights theta i id
from a same distribution row zero
and at each step
we sample a new xkyk
from okay the training data
and we update the weights theta i as t
i k plus one equal to theta ik plus
epsilon the step size times
the
gradient of the square loss
evaluated at x k y k
so the question is
similarly to the approximation theory so
what are the properties of neural
networks reached by sgd
so for example do they have small test
error
the like is sgd finding a near global
minimizer
or is it getting stuck to a local bad
minimizer
other question is
artists neural networks reached by sgd
insensitive to the number of neurons
as long as it's large enough and the
dimension d so similarly to the
approximation theory
so these questions are fairly fairly
difficult
but there is a recent analysis that
naturally connected sgd dynamics and
approximation theory
so it was uh proposed in parallel
by uh four different groups in 2019
18.
and so this is mean field theory
and so what they proved is that
sgd dynamics
emits an asymptotic description as the
number of neurons goes to infinity and
the step size epsilon goes to zero
and so in this limit
the sgd dynamics is described by a
nonlinear pde
in the space of probability distribution
on the space of parameters
let me describe at this
mean field limit
uh so first of all we assume the
following we assume that we do a one
pass sgd
so the training examples are never
revisited
so we denote
the empirical measure
over the theta ik so the weights
obtained after k steps sgd one passes gd
so we step size epsilon
and so t synthesization id with row zero
and so what they showed is that uh
rho hat
and t over epsilon so
the t over epsilon steps converges
uh and probably like a weekly to
in distribution to roti
um
okay
and this tea
evolve
according to a pde
which is of my kin of less of type
so the partial derivative of roti is
equal to the divergence of protein times
the gradient of this potential psi theta
roti
so
psychedelity is a sum of uh
external potential vitita plus a
pairwise potential so utila prime
and this is referred to as a mean field
description or distributional dynamics
it has a nice mathematical structure so
this is a gradient flow on the risk
row
in the space of probability distribution
and load with the vacherstein metric
so to make it to make it more concrete i
wanted to
give an illustration of this framework
so
here i chose the following simple uh
example so
we take a data distribution yx
and we have with probability one half
y equal to plus one uh x is distributed
according to
uh normal distribution with covariance
uh sigma plus
uh with probability one half
we have y equals minus 1 and x is
a gaussian vector with covariance sigma
minus
and so we take this sigma plus minus
to be equal to this
u
diagonal
diagonal
diagonal matrix one plus minus delta
squared
uh
so on the first s0
coordinates and
one on the d minus s0 that's coordinates
you transpose so use an orthogonal
matrix so basically we assume that the
difference between uh y equal plus 1 and
y equals minus 1 is
the variance
of x on this
span by the first s0
uh
columns of hue
so and we call this subspace v and we
call pv the projection anti-subspace
so on the right side there is
my artistic take on this classification
problem
and so we consider furthermore this
activation function so just a ridge
function
so sigma is just a
function of the inner product of x and w
and so the goal will be to study sgd on
this population risk
so let me just comment a bit this
setting so it's rather simple
it will allow us to
write quite explicitly the
distributional dynamics
but it's not that trivial in the sense
that
so a good classifier
would need to
be able to find the subspace v
so meaning that sjd we need to be able
to
find
a feature nonlinear feature sigma x w
align with v
among like
many that are are purely equivalent
two points at the red points are the
axis right
yes that's the dx
and they
so so here it's a kind of high dimension
so like like a projected from a high
dimensional space
so they're like on the so that's why for
example you can
classify up to zero uh
risk
is because you have concentration on
the shot
yes
um just to make sure is it a typo that
you don't have an ai outside or is this
just not there is no ai
so it's just uh much easier for the
analysis
um
but it's still like very difficult me
yes
you got straight forward how to analyze
which is actually up here
okay let me
describe a bit more this distributional
dynamics in this case
[Music]
so in this problem we have x y
that is in varying under rotation on the
subspace of v and the subspace
orthogonal to v
so this observation allows us to
simplify a lot to the dynamic so if we
denote r1 the norm of w projected on v
and r2 the norm of w projected
orthogonal to v then
if
the initial distribution where 0 is
uniform condition on r1 r2 then ro t the
solution of the distributional dynamic
will also be uniform a conditional on r1
r2
so like roti will have this form
and so for example this is the case if
we take rho 0 spherical
symmetric which is usually the case
and plus because of james inequality
global optimum will be of this type so
we don't need to look at other
initialization
okay so
the pd of roti now simplified to a pda
on row bar t
which is two dimensional where and you
can also write explicitly the pde
okay so we have a pd in two dimensions
instead of d dimensions
so we can efficiently solve it
numerically but we can also write it
and classify the stationary points
and so song andrea and
fan
prove the following is that if we have
some good initialization row zero bar
and activation sigma and they take the
setting where s0
so the dimension of the subspace where
you have a difference between
plus one and minus one
so as your scale has gamma d
then so the pd converges to a global
optimal in a time t
that doesn't depend on the dimension it
will only depend on delta gamma and the
initial
initial
distribution reserve bar
okay so here
i put some um
simulations from
song andre and fan papers
uh so
on top
so here uh we took uh like they take a
review activation so they are just ai
and offset bi and so now the
distribution instead of being
two-dimensional it's four-dimensional
so here
the plot is the risk
the population population risk against
the number of iterations of sgd
and so you compare
sgd so the cross
and the pde so the continuous line
and for example you see that
okay the like for delta the three delta
chosen here
you reach
near
zero minimizer
so near global minimizer
and the structure of this uh
of the evaluation of sgd is kind of
complicated so there is this flat region
here
and
this behavior is well captured by
the distributional dynamics
so on the bottom i
instead of plotting some statistics i
just
put like the
distribution projected on
r1
so
blue is just the histogram empirical
histogram of sgd
and the red line is the solution of the
pde
and this is for three different types
okay so
one other thing is that
sgd does not always converge to the
global optimum
and thanks to
writing explicitly tspd we can
find examples where sgd fails
so this is one so
here
we take the activation function to be
non-monotonic
so you have like
this
facet drop and then go back up
and
in this case so we plot
the risk against the number of
iterations again
and
so we start with two different
initialization so normal with two
different variants
so kappa squared over d with kappa
equals 0.1 and kappa equals 0.4 and what
happens is that if kappa equals 0.4 you
convert your global optima
if kappa equals 0.1
so you start
very close to zero
and
so the um
network with just a direct on zero is a
stationary point in that case and so you
see that
uh you converge to this stationary point
so this is just
all weights have
alright four to zero basically
okay so
i thought this example so it's been
filled a good theory for lgd
so first of all
one good thing is that mean field is uh
independent of n which is an empirical
observation
uh that sgd
as long as n is large enough is fairly
incense insensitive to
the number of parents
uh a second good thing about sgd is that
uh in some cases so for example the
example like this uh an isotropic ocean
it uh simplify a lot the analysis
so for example it factors at
some landscape complexities of neural
networks
so the permutation in variance of the
neurons
it allows to exploit symmetries in the
data distribution which is
not the case if you have only a finite
number of neurons
and you can focus on studying a pde
and so global convergence stationary
points etc
and of course
for this approach to be meaningful we
need to answer the following question so
in what regime
is a distributional dynamics a good
approximation to sgd
and so for example
if the num if to
if in order for sgd to be well
approximated by the distribution of
dynamics you need the
number of neurons
to scale exponentially in the dimension
uh then it's a bad theory because
like as soon as d is a few dozen
uh
like uh
the distribution dynamics will only uh
uh model like very unrealistic
uh
large networks
another thing is that uh in some
examples you can actually
see that sgd is fairly insensitive to
the dimension d and that would not be
captured
by the distribution of dynamics if it
depends on the okay
so more concretely so more precisely so
what we want to show is that
we
take theta case so the weights after
case steps of one pass sgd so again we
step size epsilon and
initial weights theta i zero id with row
zero and we do not rotate the solution
of the distributional dynamics with same
initialization
and so the goal is uh so it is why to
compare the population risks
and so
we want to be able to show the following
is that for a given time horizon
big t
with probability at least one minus
delta
we have
the risk uh up to time t
uh the difference between the two
dynamics
uh bounded by an error that is explicit
in time
epsilon
uh big n and delta
and other quantities
so here will be the assumptions for such
a bomb
so we'll consider
the following
type of activation function so we'll
take the parameters theta to be composed
of a scalar a and a vector w of
dimension big d minus one and so the
activation function will be a times
sigma x w so here it's not necessarily
an inner product between x and w
um so we'll denote
the potential v theta
with uh factoring out the a so it is v w
and u w and w 2 will be like this
potential with this
sigma
activation function
and
so we'll make the following assumptions
so those are fairly standard for people
that
know about uh like results in
propagation of keras so we
assume that sigma and y are bounded
so with a little bit of work you can
show that sigma you can take sigma and
bound it with the um okay so basically
here if sigma is bounded you can't
attack a value for example
um
okay so here what we want then is for
any w the gradient of sigma with w is a
sub gaussian
so with respect to x
then we um
so in the second time we assume that the
potentials
uh there are differential uh
differentiable with banded and lip
sheets gradients
and the third
assumption is that
the initialization row 0 is supported on
so for
the parameter a
bounded
so we have like this constants k1 k2 k3
and so we'll consider two cases
so one is with general coefficients
so we initialize the parameters with
this
uh distribution
row zero
and we update both ai's and wi's during
the dynamics
and the second
case will be
fixed coefficients so we do the same
initialization but
we only update wi and we fix the ai at
their initial
like initial value
and so for example in the second case
the
distributional dynamics will be d minus
one dimensional instead of d
okay so the bound that we get is the
foreign so sigma star uh verifies the
assumptions
uh from the previous slide so we take
the time arise and t
okay bigger than one
and in the case of the fixed
coefficients we prove that
there exists
a constant k that depends only on
the assumptions
a1 to a3
so that with probability at least one
minus exponential of minus z squared we
get this bound
so
k exponential of kt times squared log n
plus z over square root of n
plus this which
now has quite a d plus log n times
square root of epsilon
in the case of general coefficients
we'll get exactly the same bound but
with
exponential of kt replaced by
exponential of k c cubed
all right so here i just revert the
bound
so
the first part is the error that
is incurred by taking a finite number of
neurons the second is the error due to
the
discretization of the dynamic in time
so provided that t and k are constants
like of order one so the mean field
approximation is accurate
as soon as the number of nodes is
large enough
independent of d
and large enough like
which uh
only depend on interesting properties of
the activation and data distribution
so only depend on this uh
k
so this is kind of reminiscent to the
baron theorem
so in in
in the baron theorem so the question is
how many neurons do you need to
approximate the
global minima and here the question is
how many neurons do you need to
approximate the
sgd dynamics
and so for the step size we need hyphen
smaller than one over d
and so again like a bit more explanation
so why did we call it dimension free
bound so n does not depend directly on
big d
so only on t say k has and okay t
so
the k i's so these constants in the
assumption can potentially depend on d
uh however like in baron
there is a number of settings uh that
are interesting where these constants
don't depend on the and this is for
example
uh the case for this classifying
centered anisotropic
gaussian setting so i recall
uh this covariance matrices
sigma plus minus and so we have
the subspace
with the difference between the two
distribution of dimension
so s0 equal gamma d
so
i increase with linearly with d
we take sigma the activation function to
be a truncated value
so we i mean you can take it a bit more
generally but basically this is
uh
interesting example
and so we take the
uh initial uh distribution
rho bar zero to have some good
properties
so meaning that it has bounded density
with respect to labor measure enters
like somehow a good start so the risk
at uh
the risk with row bar zero is slightly
less than one
that case
so
uh
song andrea and fine showed that you
converge in a time that is independent
in the dimension so we can use our
bound
to get
the following theorem so for any eta
delta
big delta and small data so there exists
constant
d0 c0 and t
so that for any d so the dimension of
the input bigger than
d0 so which is a constant
the number of neurons began bigger than
this constant c0
and epsilon less than one over d c0
then if you take
the number of gradient steps to be t
over epsilon
or stochastic
step t over epsilon then with
probability at least one minus delta
uh the risk at theta k
is within epsilon from the global minima
and so here in this setting we showed
that
for a number of neurons
of order one number of samples of order
d
so one pass sgd finds a near global
minimizer of the population risk
and so here i insist on population risk
so
it's different than
several other approaches that show that
you converge to zero
training risk
so here in this framework you directly
show
that the
solution found by sgd generalized as
well
and uh okay so in this case we were able
to elucidate the dependency of the
number of neurons and number of samples
in terms of
the dimension d
so
unfortunately these bands are not
quantitative in terms of the other
parameters so for example eta
but
it's already interesting
so this is the
global strategy
so to show
uh quantitative global convergence for
with
lgd within like this framework is that
you first show
global convergence of the distribution
dynamic
so there are some
results
that
showed like some
sufficient condition for it to happen
like for example suzanne back
so the second step would be to bond the
time to convergence so tc
so here there is almost no results
except like
one
with java mod marco andrea from 2019
where they take a setting
where the pd is almost
like near a pd that is displacement
connects
okay so the third
part of this recipe is the bound between
sgd and the pde
so right now
the band that we have is exponential in
t
so uh like this one will only work if
the time to convergence is much smaller
than log n so if it's uh doesn't depend
on d
basically
um
but okay so t strategy already applies
to some non-trivial examples and so this
uh and isotropic gaussians was one of
them
okay so like sometimes so here i'll just
briefly mention
uh that um so if you're interested in
working on this min field uh description
uh you might want to
uh choose a noisy sgd which has like
some interesting properties
so noisy sgd is basically lgd where you
add a gaussian isotropic noise at each
step
um
so they're independent and
kind of like this variance epsilon of a
beta
in that case so the distribution
dynamics now is simply the same with
this extra diffusion term so one over
beta so beta inverse temperature
and
delta the laplacian
and this again has a nice
mathematical structure
so this is a gradient flow
in the
vascular steiner space of distribution
for the free energy
so
our rho the population is minus one over
beta the entropy of rho
in that case okay so
uh for this uh when you add this
diffusion term then you can prove uh
global convergence the dynamic towards
the global minimizer of the free energy
and under some regularity conditions you
can show that this global minimizer is
also
a near global minimizer for the risk
function
our rho star beta so if you take beta
large enough you'll also reach
a near global optimizer
of the
applications
okay
so in this for this
noisy
dynamic we get similarly a
bound
like bounce between the
sgd dynamics and the pde
so for fixed coefficients we get exactly
the same down
for general coefficients so it's harder
to control
uh so we get like okay it's a bit messy
uh but basically it's not dimension free
anymore meaning that you have like this
d here so you need n to be
to scale uh bigger than d
and the second thing is that this band
is now double exponential in t in the
time
so this
this band will allow to
control this approximation
up to
a time t that is log log n instead of
log n for the
other bounds
yes
one more time the difference
what you mean by the fixed component so
fixed coefficients you fix the a so you
have activation function that is a sigma
and so you fix the a so the sigma are
just bounded now so it's much easier to
do the
propagation of chaos argument
and for general coefficients so what
happens is that you have this
coefficient in front of sigma and so you
need to bound the
how big they're becoming basically
uh so here i have
i guess some more time
uh so i just like briefly mentioned like
outline the proof for this dimension
free bond so they're fairly like you
know not not very complicated it's just
a bit tedious
uh so the ingredients is uh
for this proof is uh so carefully
isolating uh the different error terms
uh doing a coupling at initialization
for
different dynamics and doing like
carefully concentration of major
arguments
and so basically the idea is
we'll consider four different
uh coupled dynamics
and i will
bound
the
distance between each of them
and so the first dynamic is just you
take n particles theta i bar
which are
initialized i deal with zero zero
and you make them evolve uh with this
velocity field from the
distribution
dynamic the second dynamic so you take n
particles
so same initialization so you couple
them through
uh
theta i zero
and
now you make them
like
like so particle dynamics just gradient
descent on the population risk with
n particles
then uh the third dynamic is just
discrete gradient descent on the
population loss and the fourth dynamic
is just
a stochastic gradient descent on the
population loss so
one past stochastic but understand the
population loss and again like all these
four dynamics are coupled through their
initialization
in that case uh okay so you bound
the difference between the risks by
using this dynamics as interpolation
and now it's uh fairly uh you know
straightforward so each time is some uh
concentration like as you molding or mac
damage inequality followed by
groundwall's inequality
so you can find the details of this
proof in
mean field theory of two layers neural
networks so
from that cult 2019
okay final remarks
um
so mean field theory so it's a
theory that described sgd for number of
neurons going to infinity and uh this
like step size going to zero so in terms
of pde in the space of probability
distributions
uh so it allows to focus on key elements
of the dynamics so global convergence
stationary points
and in some cases it's
very tractable
so here i presented some dimension free
bounds
so to approximate the sgd
dynamics with
the distributional dynamics we only need
the number of neurons to
be
bigger than a constant that depends on
intrinsic properties of the activation
and data distribution
i also emphasize that capturing this
dimension
dependence
of
sgd on neural networks is crucial in
order to compare neural networks to
other learning methods so for example
kernel methods lately
and so there is a lot of
open problems so global global
convergence guarantees
bounding the convergence time so
improving this uh exponential dependency
in t
going to multi-layer etcetera etcetera
thank you that's all i have today
questions
good yeah um so uh i wonder about batch
size right so i think what you're doing
is a batch size of one right for sg yes
and this is not often used in practice
because the noise is too large
so
can you use larger batch sizes in the
framework and how
if it's still one plus there's no
difference sorry if it's a one-pass if
you don't reuse samples like all this
analysis will go through
so
you have a question regarding the global
convergence guarantee
so other than the language i mean at the
noise is there any other
like a normal result that can guarantee
the convergence of the the memphian
dynamics
other than uh schizoid
all right other than the lingering
algorithms i mean
other than the
[Music]
so there are arguments from uh optimal
transport so by schezenbach and
basically uh what they do is that they
assume
the
um
so first of all they take uh
okay i guess uh one or two homogeneous
activation functions
and
they take an initialization
that is uh
isotropic more or less spread out
and
they assume that the
uh
natural t converges to a row infinity
and so if you if you assume all of that
then they show that uh rainfall it is
actually a global minimizer yeah but
that is not the equivalent of saying
that convergence to i mean the global
convergence right
it converges yeah yeah you assume that
it's converging to a solution but uh
i think
yeah
while here
you get convergence
and it doesn't
yeah that is uh
of course
so um
this is more general not just like the
data set that you consider here
but maybe
i'm asking and then a kind of a
follow-up is so um uh
still the sgd is agnostic to this
structure is that correct or does it you
know does the algorithm explode
and if suppose it's the case
uh what would what would be maybe a
strategy to
if you don't know what the signatures
are but maybe you believe are there
somehow
how could this be perhaps explored
so i mean about this symmetry so like
here we took a uh like a an example that
is highly symmetric
uh just to
um
simplify the the
like analysis of
like analytical analysis of the
distribution dynamics
but uh you you might have like uh
problems that are not symmetric and i
still have like this uh constraint in
the assumptions that don't depend on
the dimension
so it's uh
and you can have t symmetries and have
constants that
depend on the dimension
so this is
kind of different but it's just uh in
this case it was uh
you can directly study the plea
instead of like um
using abstract
arguments
yeah this is perhaps more of a comment
but i wanted to say you can weaken the
design that assumption a little bit in
the sense that you only need convergence
of the function that is represented and
then you can show that the risk goes to
zero but obviously that doesn't tell you
that you converge to a minimizer or in
fact that you convert to anything so you
need a much weaker convergence only
and the uh without the noise
without noise so
in retrospect if i known this talk
before i would have given a talk about
that but the other and the other comment
is that
there are some newer results from i
think 2020 from the bruner zhang dao
chain eric london heinen and brad
roskoff
that say that
if your
risk decays quickly enough you do not
get this exponential blow up in time so
then you actually do get convergence for
all time
closeness for all time
but obviously you make a strong
assumption that the risk decays quickly
the risk converges faster than which
converges um if there is convert if the
risk decays i think a little bit faster
than one over t squared and that's hard
to prove
but then you then you don't have the
separation from the discrete to the
continuum
but i think in this business they're
really different
you know
you know challenging question is for
which
high-dimensional tv i mean this whole
business can work quality of convergence
in time independent of the dimension
right so the really difficult
mathematical question for p people here
is
for which pde i can prove convergence
guarantees to global optimum for which
masters are closed
in time independent of the dimension
if anybody is ideal to do these proofs
please
right there here we go continue but i
think we should move on so let's thank
uh
[Applause]